Hold on.
Bravo.
How might you spend Sandoz Ciba [inaudible] I think I went off my horse.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] barbies.
I C K?
No.
My thought
is that one.
I see.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] just go on this story
one on one.
I started at
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] sewers phobia.
So there's mirrors and make us all frio is Miller [inaudible] on medical
[inaudible] in [inaudible] north main Wanda [inaudible] phobia or getting up for
[inaudible] him and approximately
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] data [inaudible] denim
getting us where we are free or one or the energy star and or as part of the
magic what Ron knew that we die and
[inaudible] [inaudible] Catherine [inaudible] Buco cable.
Lori's has happened.
Needles,
I mean the you.
Hmm.
[inaudible] I love what I made.
I started in
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a three or four Maria.
But the COC day,
they may pass you on the me,
the Milano [inaudible] this [inaudible] on Alawa,
eh?
[inaudible].
Is it real or is it implicate?
They
[inaudible] [inaudible] Oh,
nice.
Khaki TM
goal is Martin [inaudible] and I said
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] he came in [inaudible] and free or no,
the idea.
Okay.
We're getting
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] won't even bigger as well,
but there's a
lot of,
yeah,
it's been a
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] as the areas,
but,
uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] per case and where they fit.
[inaudible] is
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] personas because they can be idea,
but I get to [inaudible] instead of [inaudible] but Okeydokey one or two bonus
total two quarter Pato to make that worthwhile.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] somebody open Amila
Maxima.
Bridgestone is like I said,
well,
no,
me,
his mom in me maximum [inaudible] la where they,
especially if you're not only because fairly thin,
you know the lung condition
[inaudible] [inaudible] but this was [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] moment.
But I would add if you're not a lottery that super quirky or 51 [inaudible] but
it's important that [inaudible] have is the responsibility at the established
yon.
But again,
like on [inaudible]
[inaudible] is that how he said
[inaudible] [inaudible] and
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] they trust in us.
[inaudible] in Dallas.
What [inaudible] smells my motive and non there just as the London [inaudible]
way random.
So number
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] was posters.
Fourth Bertha guests get monitor.
Look,
I said
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] then the
[inaudible] [inaudible] no.
[inaudible] this was Sunday.
You know,
he took us from coming [inaudible] Kathy to Damion say [inaudible] is having
more skeleton [inaudible] feedback.
[inaudible] [inaudible] ready though to enter another
comparison.
Both two.
I still,
the rest of your feedback for kissing and the parity can be a terrible feedback.
The I told you,
or in or an happy Europe.
[inaudible] Como Si
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] reporting or on
[inaudible] [inaudible] is a vocal local persecution.
But then the culture,
but in Eddie say it will come in and Roy ECI feedbacks postcard.
What I'm
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] point.
Mikaila halt any,
I gave her her labia megawatt.
So,
so ba,
but there's metric Greco steer to wake a moment.
We don't can filter in.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] business was making a fee,
but again,
[inaudible] exactly.
I'm as the man likes [inaudible] putting me down maximum.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] vanilla
armies,
mothers on [inaudible].
Um,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
okay.
I want to be so good.
[inaudible] you Damion [inaudible] Ambien Nigga
[inaudible] [inaudible] fast heater,
my artistic us and those Como,
but now may simply man can tell a lot of,
they smell I'm fat outdoors.
The middle of last year.
[inaudible] personal say
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] was the last [inaudible] I'll never see ad.
The more you can tell
when the pogo,
same way our customer
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] e
going
to try to wrap up to Eh for my party.
The
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] then [inaudible]
one of the,
cause you get alone low without
[inaudible].
They care competitors.
I said the written de la [inaudible] la
[inaudible] [inaudible]
no.
[inaudible] the [inaudible] and do [inaudible].
Andrea was slow.
The whole,
the whole report,
but maybe so land the personal I coupon.
We professionally call multimodal and are not
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Mucho Mars.
No.
[inaudible] rolling.
Because Andrei controversial barriers.
The report,
the interferon unit,
they suppose.
Suppose Baskin Fec does not represent them.
This
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] is that I can professional
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] experience.
They look a lot,
but in the end,
the designers and last Alexion at [inaudible] no more.
If we're the biggest one,
kick it.
Okay.
Okay,
well give us a longer and a coupon and spending more info.
Girls moving there in other one on us must fasten,
but there's more that if he can [inaudible] they way up in the,
in the book up Oregon.
See [inaudible] for the manager.
[inaudible]
see [inaudible] me see
[inaudible] [inaudible]
it's developmental.
Monica,
see on your grill game?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] component as a,
like you're putting in Colorado is done.
They didn't get eradicated in castle rock is Hamas for
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] important that transmit data store,
right.
[inaudible] was [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] ultra Hogan Sunday earlier EIC record,
which is in my Lucien
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] time.
Yup.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] that make it our Selena,
but of woke up.
Okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
when there's an experiential memory that difficult,
they put the game
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] one of the Malcolm
[inaudible] [inaudible] the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] last name [inaudible].
Okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] don't they?
When I moved to
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Amazon Nardo okay.
I'd go out at this was,
no,
no one
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I guess have any
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Benson law and in Las Vegas and [inaudible].
Yeah,
I would say about
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
take it easy.
[inaudible] I want to go and get those logos.
Yeah.
Vidoe and nothing.
No.
One of the one a little bit,
but it wouldn't,
I,
they listen to me.
There's light.
If you see an appetite in the fourth day here,
you see what?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] yesterday.
It is a beginner.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and there's no Sir
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
but when [inaudible]
was rolled down,
codename
low
back
the PC.
Okay.
Last name.
Your style?
I think
go more
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] which I'm
not saying can I?
Okay.
[inaudible] he says [inaudible] naturally that the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
I sent that out,
but it gets,
you know
as much,
as much as well as [inaudible]
and
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I guess.
No,
but I wouldn't that aim,
I will never wrote [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
eh,
but there's many ones like a,
yeah,
but I think I get bought out of it.
[inaudible]
doing
a sprint and then referred to the birthday
or whatever,
or I'm either could
do service around that size,
isn't it?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
there's the blind,
right?
Martha [inaudible]?
No.
[inaudible]
no.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] 30 [inaudible] got it
told.
Hmm.
Gotcha.
Is
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and [inaudible] gay
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] is going to scan.
There's no,
no,
that [inaudible]
important.
There's supposed to be
[inaudible] diva.
Hmm.
Could give us a call.
[inaudible]
so what does [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] but this is more important.
Tip was
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] okay.
[inaudible] Halloween,
I guess.
When are you
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
well,
I know.
What am I going to waste my time?
I say good.
Did He tell you sitting on your funnel and where does it
[inaudible] there's the [inaudible] [inaudible].